so the last time a party in congress
officially designated the other party a
terrorist organization we were in the
middle of a civil war
so that hasn't happened in over 150
years typically the parties argue about
things sometimes they get mad they call
each other names sometimes they get
really mad and call each other really
bad names but one thing they don't do
is use law enforcement
to crush harass arrest
voters on the other side because that's
not democracy that's tyranny
but we've just moved one step closer to
tyranny in fact we may already be there
thanks to what the house is calling an
anti-domestic terrorism bill as if
murder wasn't illegal already
it just passed the house and it
instructs the fbi to quote analyze and
monitor domestic terrorist activity so
how are we defining that of course we're
not defining that
it instructs the fbi in other words the
largest law enforcement organization in
the united states to monitor
joe biden's critics it dramatically
expands the definition of
domestic terror
to include hate crimes
whatever those are it also mandates that
the fbi and the doj conduct an
assessment to determine whether white
supremacists have quote infiltrated
federal state and local law enforcement
agencies now what's a white supremacist
they don't define that either
so if you're going to pass a law that
empowers people with guns to make
arrests you probably should define your
terms otherwise it will be abused
unless the law was designed to be abused
and this one was
so under this law these law enforcement
agencies must
issue bi-annual domestic terrorism
reports to congress with a focus on the
threat quote posed by white supremacists
and neo-nazis because it turns out the
only form of race discrimination in the
country comes from one group and they
don't vote for democrats that's the
whole point that's why the bill doesn't
mention blm or nt for black nationalists
and as we said it doesn't define white
supremacy and that's very odd because
white supremacy is the only thing
lawmakers talked about as they voted on
this bill
recent white supremacist attacks have
reminded minority communities across the
country of a dark history we have not
yet escaped
we have witnessed far too many other
acts of domestic terrorism
we are at an important crossroads in
this country with white supremacy on the
rise and violent extremists fueling each
other's bigotry and hate we're seeing an
alarming increase in domestic terrorism
fueled by this hatred
now keep in mind when you hear people
like that and those are some of the
worst and most limited people in our
society but still they're elected
members of congress when you when you
hear them attack white supremacists and
white supremacy you should know that
their definition of those terms is
probably different from yours so if you
were to quote martin luther king jr
whose monument stands on the mall and
say that the u.s government ought to
treat people based on who they are and
what they do and not how they look and
how they were born
should assess people on the content of
their character not the color of their
skin if that's your position you are by
definition according to people you just
saw a white supremacist
this is scary
congressman corey bush of missouri
spelled out the purpose of the bill
which of course is entirely political
quote the republican party has become
the party of unfettered white
supremacist violence
so there's only one republican who voted
for this bill that's a man who's become
completely undone and who's
whose total destruction as a man really
does deserve your pity and that's adam
kinzinger here's why he said he voted
for it
people like marjorie taylor green
uh you know people like matt gates mo
brooks the folks you think about um they
are almost leading well i would argue
that they are leading the republican
caucus and so kevin mccarthy elise
stefanik instead of leading as you know
their title leadership should suggest
they do they basically are tolerating
this all in the name of hopefully i
become speaker someday you can't
fundraise you can't feed you can't live
on fear
because eventually you're going to
create fearful people and fearful people
can do really bad things and i think
that's what we saw in buffalo
so they're continuing to tell you in the
face of all available evidence that the
mass murder you saw over the weekend in
buffalo was inspired by hateful
right-wing rhetoric when in fact that
mass murder was committed by someone
with diagnosed mental illness that the
adults around him apparently ignored
okay so you saw a shooting by a crazy
person that has been hijacked by
partisan forces to crush political
dissent to attack civil liberties in
this country you should care about that
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight